the most important thing is to start off
with the business plan of saying I want
everybody to hear to this you know yeah
you know and there's and to be
comfortable with that to get the most
people to listen or the mother to
promote yourself is is not so much the
idea is to promote this thing that you
have done you know you know there is a
difference if you're a Kardashian you
are promoting yourself you're promoting
this this idea of the Kardashians yeah
but if you're a novelist or or or or a a
you know a cinematographer or or you've
written you know you've written songs
these are things that that are important
to you these are like children you know
these are these are these are these are
creations that you want people to see
and to experience because you spend a
lot of time on them and they're
important you know when I first started
I I just knew I wanted everybody in the
world to hear one song of I you know I
you know I thought of like this land is
your land by Woody Guthrie and I thought
that's the most amazing song and and and
everybody knows it and that'd be so
amazing if people knew a song of mine if
you're ambitious you have to be honest
with your ambitions and and say it's not
you know you know you can you can be the
best and and the smartest and the
cleverest and and most talented
songwriter but if you just assume that
that that you don't need to promote this
song or whatever it is that if you don't
feel the need to do that if you get your
own strength from from hiding it away
from the world then no one's ever gonna
hear it and no one's really gonna care
so I'd say like just start off and be
honest with yourself and say like the
the world needs to hear what you got to
say and and and and and and and you
deserve to deserve to be able to go out
there and then show
you